it was reaction Fox News contributor
kellyanne Conway former governor of
Arkansas Mike Huckabee and Fox News
contributor Ari Fleischer kellyanne we
start with you you're really good with
numbers so
when we go back to 2016 if we take the
three swing states that Donald Trump won
combined total votes 70 000. that's not
a lot if you look at 2020 and you look
at Arizona Georgia Wisconsin you're
talking about 43 000 votes kellyanne so
when I look at the polls in Georgia and
I look at the polls in New Hampshire and
Pennsylvania and Nevada and Arizona
although Paul has uh Blake Masters up by
three today
and I look at those polls am I wrong in
believing that probably every one of
those races or the power in the Senate
will be determined by tens of thousands
of votes and not hundreds of thousands
yes Sean you're right that's the way our
elections have been going and that's why
these are called swing States they
literally sit on the razor's Edge and it
depends obviously on turnout but it also
depends on motivation and what I call
investing in the non-sexy part of
politics okay everybody sees the ads
they see the rallies the campaign the
candidate direct appeals the TV
interviews what they don't see is who's
investing in data and digital how many
volunteers you have how many voter
contacts have you made I don't really
know what the DNC is doing but the RNC
has done a great job on this as have all
the Committees they raise over 300
million dollars and spent it they have
over 100 million voter contacts think
about that you're calling voters and
you're at the party talking about
inflation crime education immigration
border security National Security
Financial security physical security in
your communities they have over 1
million volunteers and you see that all
these these these candidates have been
very well resourced and I think what's
happened late in the game people like
Mark Kelly and the woman in Nevada with
three names and no accomplishments and
fetterman and certainly Warnock Warnock
who had no big uh National Democratic
Stars he had John ossoff his the other
Senator there these guys didn't go down
I don't know if they've given up on
Warnock but nobody really went there for
him lately they probably didn't want to
be near Stacy Abrams about to be a
two-term two-time biggest loser but this
is important because all the candidates
I just mentioned the Democrats they
haven't been anywhere near 50 in the
polls in a long time that's bad for the
party in power so when you see those
narrow margins everybody's vote counts
but even in 2020 at the house level
there were 27 toss-ups Republicans won
all or all or most of them in 2018 there
were number of races not about 17 races
not called an election night in the
house Sean because they were so close
Democrats ended up ended up winning most
of those so if you didn't get out to
vote yet remember day of voting is still
a rich tradition in this country you
take the time to do things every single
day and Independence swing voters if
you're out there saying I hate both
parties they're not different the
parties have never been more different
one is for energy Independence and a
sound economy and lower crime one is
simply not one didn't even listen to you
Sean in addition to asking people are
you better off here's the question in
2022 which party saw you heard you
listened to you and responded to you
that's a big question and it's clear
that's the Republicans Ari you are
you're looking at the big picture here
this is not your first rodeo all of us
have been down this road all of the
foundational issues are there for the
Republicans to have a way of election it
doesn't happen though unless the people
actually get out and vote there's not a
single thing they can run on that's that
is a success for them uh where do you
see this going tomorrow
the Republicans are going to take the
house and the Republicans are going to
take the Senate I think that's that
simple you know the first race I ever
worked on Sean was 1982. Ronald Reagan's
first midterm election and Republicans
lost 26 seats it was a wave for the
Democrats a president's first midterm is
always tough on the president with one
exception in the last 60 years and that
was George W bush who because of
September 11th and his great popularity
at that time he won seats the
Republicans did in the house and the
Senate this year for Joe Biden the man
has a 42 percent job approval that's
abysmally low the nation by 70 percent
thinks we're on the wrong track and the
economy is terrible marry that to a
first term election it's the kiss of
death for the party in power Republicans
are going to take the house Sean I think
they'll end up with about 230 seats and
I think Republicans in the Senate I
predicted to you last week a 25 chance
that Republicans would have a sweep
meaning 56 seats I think it's up to
about a 33 percent chance now it's been
a good week since last week for
Republican the trend continues so
Republicans will take the Senate
probably with 53 or 54 seats but I can
see a 33 percent chance of Republicans
ending up with 56 seats let me let me
take a break uh Governor we're going to
get to you in a second we're going to
dip into president Trump he's in Ohio
big crowd tonight for JD Vance
and he's expected to make a big
announcement tonight I'm not allowed to
have a jury this is the beginning of
Communism likewise a local left-wing D.A
in Atlanta is after me for an absolutely
perfect phone call about election
Integrity even while Atlanta has among
the highest murder rates per capita of
any city in the country and they
actually are higher than per capita
worse than Chicago which is a disaster
and all of these local democrat-run
cases are being directed by Washington
D.C it's part of the Witch Hunt they've
gone on the largest Witch Hunt in
history I have gone through the largest
Witch Hunt in the history
of our country and it's a disgrace and
you know a friend of mine very smart guy
came up to me said you've been going
through this for six and a half years
you have to be the most honest person
it's true can you imagine 11 million
pages of documents they've examined and
they got nothing
they have a person
they have one person that they're
torturing torturing think of this about
a company-owned car didn't pay tax on a
company I didn't pay tax on a company on
department they called fringe benefits
uh didn't report
that I paid the education for his
grandchildren a very good man 75 years
old they're torturing him because they
want him to say anything bad about Trump
say something bad they put them in
handcuffs a friend of mine owns a big
accounting firm he said there's never
been a case like this before they have
persecuted this man in order for him to
say something and then ultimately they
are from a deal you go to jail for a
couple of weeks or a couple of months or
you go to jail for many years
he said I have to say this is what think
of what they did anybody out here would
probably take a deal like that I
wouldn't I'll be honest I wouldn't but
they torture and this is what they used
to do and do currently in communist
countries and that's where we're going
that's where we're going to think of it
handcuffs walked in front a man that
never heard of jail before a man that
never had a problem with anything before
handcuffs and they perk walked him in
front of the press in handcuffs and
nobody has ever been criminally charged
in this country from what we understand
on a fringe benefit case a company-owned
car think of that didn't pay tax on a
company or company owned department and
they say that very few people do
how many people I wonder how many people
here have a company-owned car anybody
have a company do you pay taxes or do
you know what cover your face please you
pay tax
Uncle Sam do you have a company owned
car please
I guarantee even Uncle Sam probably
doesn't pay tax you know but it's a it's
a shame it's a shame when I see what's
going on it's a shame our country is
really going to hell we have a
weaponized Department of Justice and a
weaponized FBI including of course the
raid of Mar-A-Lago in the document hoax
case
totally violating my fourth amendment
rights and no president has ever been
treated this way Clinton you know the
sock case he had things in his socks
nothing happened to him except a great
verdict he's got a great verdict we go
by that verdict the Sox verdict but no
he had it in his socks you know that
right and others took many many
documents they take them out of the
White House they took document I'm the
only one that can't take anything
but maybe our country would be better
off if I actually had the nuclear codes
JD because our enemies would be afraid
unlike the way they are now if I had the
nuclear codes
Bill Clinton don't forget he lost the
nuclear coach twice
how do you explain that to the military
I've lost the military codes what do you
he lost a military coach twice I didn't
they're coming after me because I'm
fighting for you that's all it is
and if I wasn't leading in all these
polls I don't know if you find those
poll numbers you could put them up if
you find them back there you Geniuses
that do this stuff put them up let me
know when they're up we'll talk about
them but we have poll numbers that are
through the roof and so do Republicans
this is going to be a wave I think this
is going to be a very big wave I hope so
starting right here
the radical all right that's president
Trump he is in the state of Ohio tonight
the Buckeye state he's expected to make
a big announcement uh I've been calling
sources all day Governor Huckabee many
speculating that in fact the president
may be announcing that he's running for
president tonight uh my source is saying
that that will not be the case that he
will be announcing that he's made a
decision and that decision will be
forthcoming uh would it have mattered if
he did announce tonight
well I think it probably is better if he
holds off for a little while for two
reasons number one everybody is focused
on the midterm elections through
tomorrow night we need to get through
this and we need to put all the
attention on getting our voters out to
vote and to win these races and to win
them big and the second reason
he really would be taking away from the
focus of his own announcement in the
midst of the midterm elections if he
were to make that announcement tonight
people wouldn't be talking about it
nearly as much as they would be if he
has a date out there somewhere in the
future and he has the stage all to
himself with nothing else going on and
it will give all those press people an
opportunity to do what they love to do
and that's up on him and by the way I
want to say one thing about Chef
Boyardee Sean when I was a kid growing
up it was a luxury to have Chef Boyardee
all these people talking about it being
some kind of a [ __ ] lunch heck man I
would be thrilled to have Chef Boyardee
Governor if you like I'll send you a
case listen I like that as a kid too and
I like SpaghettiOs also but uh I
couldn't get there with my dad who liked
corned beef hash and Dinty Moore's beef
stew
um so kellyanne what what if if my
sources are correct and he's going to
the announcement is that only that he's
made up his mind and we'll be announcing
in the future
um is that a hint how do you take that
well it shouldn't be a surprise to
anyone he's made very clear that Donald
Trump agrees with the majority of
Democrats Sean that he doesn't want
Biden there in 2024 either I mean if a
majority Democrats feel that way why
shouldn't the former president if this
can be a binary choice between the
economy energy security crime under
Donald Trump and border of course and
under Joe Biden then I think it's easy
but look Donald Trump has been doing
what you see him doing right there in
the split screen he's been doing this
for a year and a half now he endorsed
candidates he wrote checks to them his
Maga Inc has spent millions and millions
of dollars in five states recently
especially he has showed up stood up
spoken up and put up for these
candidates contrast this with the
current president who can't stand at the
podium by himself in a swing state he
was in Maryland today not a swing state
he was in Union Station the other day
not a swing state in fact it's a train
station and the president went there to
to give some rails speech he was in New
York he was in California so look I
think that a number of people are
deserve a lot of credit for this going
the Republicans way but that includes
Donald Trump he's going to have a lot of
good to say tomorrow about the
candidates he endorsed the way he did
the teletown laws for them
Etc and the issue set the America first
issue set is on the ballot all right
we'll give you the last word and then
we'll uh we'll have to inform Governor
Huckabee that he will no longer soon he
will no longer be the best governor in
Arkansas history but
um Ari what's your what's your take
about the president basically saying not
announcing but saying that he's made up
his mind
yeah he's a wonderful teaser isn't he I
mean he really does know how to get the
focus on him but I I think Governor
Huckabee is exactly right Republicans
want to have the focus on Joe Biden
through election day that's one of the
reasons Republicans have been propelled
to such success Joe Biden's a very
unpopular president keep the focus on
Joe Biden whatever the president does
President Trump does after that then
we'll see and then I think it's going to
be a fascinating issue about whether
anybody challenges Donald Trump I'm
certain he's going to run Sean I just
can't imagine with all the teasing he's
done that he'll pull back I'm pretty
sure that President Donald Trump is
going to run again in the Republican
nomination then all the attention shifts
too will somebody challenge him all
right we'll find out as that
announcement gets close we'll go back to
our coverage of that uh thank you all
kellyanne thank you Governor Huckabee
good luck to Sarah tomorrow Ari
Fleischer thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else